hallo David Luka meine liebe Freunde ich
freue mich extrem auf das heutige Video
denn wir fahren heute
und auch in Köln zum Kölner Hauptbahnhof
ich soll mich hier nach rechts gucken
mit dem Ding hier fahre gleich mit dem
Vize
möchten sie ihre vertikale Achse
invertieren junge spiel ich in Mathe
oder was außerdem fahren von Zügen gibt
es viele Anforderungen für die Bewegung
zu Fuß bewegen sie sich jetzt ich kann
laufen
hallo
lieber mein Zug sehen halt's Maul
perfekt er gar das ist auf jeden Fall
der Kölner Hauptbahnhof meine lieben
Freunde da vorne ist der Rhein und hier
ist der Kölner Dom hier unten ist eine
Bar die ist nicht da gerade
hier ist eigentlich eine Bar die
kunstbar
schon oft richtig abgeschossen da
Vorname den domvorplatz sie haben mir
den Bahnhofsvorplatz dann noch den Rolex
Deutschland sitzt direkt über einem
richtig billigen Steakhouse im Kiosk
dazu beschreibt eigentlich Köln in der
nutshell darum sollte heute allerdings
gar nicht immer die Freunde sondern um
ICE wir fahren nämlich heute mit
Schnellzügen von Köln los in Richtung
keine Ahnung ich kann auch
ich kann auch runter
Norway das ist ja
das ist halt nicht der Kölner
Hauptbahnhof hier na gut meine lieben
Freunde der Kölner Hauptbahnhof wieder
auf jeden Fall nicht so aus allerdings
muss ich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
rumlaufen ist das hier ein
dies ist eine von vielen interaktiven
Handlungen aber nicht alle sind so
leicht zu entdecken okay ich kann ich
auch schnell laufen guck mal ich kann
auch Sprinter können wir alles noch ein
bisschen schneller arbeiten was ist hier
achso ich muss wie hoch Gleis 5 jetzt
mein ICE wie kannst du dann das hier
steht 2. Klasse oder steht 1. klasse das
ist ja schon wieder das ist ein
Spielfehler natürlich nicht zweite
Klasse 1 Freunde wir sprinten erstmal
direkt rüber zur ersten Klasse, das
zeigt doch direkt an hier ist im
Bordbistro nee da laufen vorbei übrigens
ganz alleine hier zweite Klasse gebucht
habt jetzt Richtung nah wie möglich an
Bord bist du denn an die Toilette
vom Profi
können wir einsteigen
umsteigen
das ist echt wenn ich auf dem Klo was
wenn ich mal pissen muss kann ich ja
Sitz 1.
ganz kurze
ich glaube ich bin so ca einzige hier
von allen Leuten die hier gerade zu
gucken aber ich liebe ja Zugfahren ist
nicht gesponsert irgendwie von ICE oder
Deutsche Bahn Alter Irish ich liebe
Zugfahren einfach deswegen ich ich füge
Regenbogen ihr
Laptop rausholen bzw und schneiden
müssen hier was essen und was will er
denn keiner sondern eine Frau guckt so
leg mich jetzt nicht auf da immer das
sollst du deiner Familie da vorne rüber
so wir wollen allerdings liegt auf dem
Tisch oder was
er springt auch nicht ich mache die Tür
auf und Tür wieder zu meiner lieben
Freundin wir laufen jetzt nämlich rüber,
das ist alles
gibt es alles genauso wie im ICE
wo fahren wir dorthin Köln Aachen liege
Brüssel und Aras Büffel okay perfekt wir
unsere Passagiere hallo guten Tag der
Herr vor den verdammten zu
jetzt auch guten Tag die Dame
[Musik]
da war doch noch wohin sonst Zeichen
dass ich dahin muss eine Stunde später
guck mal Leute das Ding jetzt hier vorne
dran ich musste doch nach hier hinten
laufen ich habe ich gerade
wahrscheinlich an der Tag was ist wenn
ich hier drauf gehe
ich kann mich nicht bewegen
ich bin im Zug
ich
so solltet ihr bitte nicht versuchen
dann einen Zug einzusteigen wir müssen
allerdings trotzdem irgendwie hier
Vorankommen ich kann jetzt nicht schon
wieder das in Neustadt nicht aber das
ist wohl noch ein bisschen schneller
eingeblendet bei Dings
ich kann
betreten Sie den Führerschein die ja
tschuldigung ich bin hier gerade im
Boden
Mission sag jetzt nicht ich häng fest ne
ich häng fest
jetzt
jetzt kann ich gar nichts machen
ich kann nichts mehr machen meine Maus
ist auch sichtbar jetzt
komm noch ein letzter Versuch so meine
Damen und Herren ich gehe jetzt nicht
aufs Gleis sondern warte hier schön bis
der ICE direkt vor meiner Nase hält die
Sprit nur noch ein bisschen weiter ich
bin schnell als TECE
ja warum soll man dem Bahnfahren kommen
heute ich trag euch einfach nach Aachen
der ICE bleibt jeden Moment stehen und
die sieht doch schon hier dort muss ich
hin als ich muss anscheinend doch nicht
direkt ins führerhäuschen sondern erst
mal hier vorne rein oder muss ich da
drauf
keine Ahnung
das ist jetzt eine Aufgabe dass ich ins
Menü gehe
okay
jetzt stehe ich allerdings wieder auf
und muss sie jetzt auch nach hier vorne
meine lieben Freunde denn nun können wir
anscheinend wirklich hier rein in
natürlich immer schön die Türschild Zeit
mit fahren verbringen setzen Sie sich
also auf den Lokführer sitzt
ich weiß nicht ob ich schon bereit dafür
bin ich
bin ganz ehrlich leute wenn ihr wollt
dass ich ein zweiten Teil von hochlade
wo ich dann diese Lok komplett einmal
aus Köln raus durch Europa Donna dann
lasst einen Daumen hoch unter dem Video
hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke wenn ihr den
Teiler nicht verpassen wollt schreibst
du unter die Kommentare wenn ihr
irgendwelche Tipps habt Luca
log-log Luca